Michael starts off this hour in Atlanta
Georgia hey Michael how are you hi Dave
let's meet our first to talk to you sir
well before my wife won the mixer I told
you how I recently converted fan over
ever since like professors I always can
see you guys so she's really excited to
actually uh to be a part of the program
now cool so my question is uh I said
memoir started taking FP we're actually
starting our first class this Saturday
coming up so we're trying to work it up
as you can live within our means and
everything else so one of our major
problems is our church we go to a small
church for retirees and what we're up
against that they we keep getting asked
to contribute to campaigns going on like
this contain two pipelines $100 for
family or or another one to our past
anniversary and not wanting money for
everything that's going on we all really
have in my view that because we're
trying to live on a budget and try to
believe are trying to stick to paying
off our debt and everything we're
finding it hard to say no because we it
we're getting combative back towards
against that so I'm trying to figure out
how do we tell them that we're trying to
so what happened is you said what would
happen what would be the reaction if you
said gosh that sounds like a really good
program and someday we'll be able to
participate in that kind of a program
right now our tithe is all we're
committed to because we're trying to
clean up our own household first which
is scriptural so yeah I'm sure you guys
understand we just can't do any more
than the tithe right now what would be
the reaction to that well we get that
well you just need to dig deep and
believe that God will take care of the
rest kind of course a response back so
kind of we get perspective
yeah okay well I wouldn't go well with
that I'm afraid I would be nice a few
times and then after that I would say
what you need to mind your own business
right on because I mean honestly what
they're saying then is is that I need
your money and it's really over the top
when somebody becomes that manipulative
on that pushy to where they come back at
you after you've given them a firm but
kind no you just need to dig deep you
just don't have enough faith well I've
got plenty of faith and I'm actually
following a scriptural plan here to get
my
my self out of debt and and you know I
you know I'm sorry you feel that way but
we won't be giving to that and after you
do that two or three times they'll
probably leave you alone okay I think I
mean you just got to be kind and the
thing is there now the other thing that
you need to dig into and you need to
think about is if every time they have
an impulse they turn it in to buy
something there because they didn't plan
for it in their money in their annual
budget at the church if every time they
have an impulse and they call that the
Holy Spirit or every time they have an
impulse their answer to that is you need
to fund this impulse and that's called
faith I'm going to start to have a
problem with leadership at that point
because they're not leading well they're
leading with an immaturity because
they're not doing good planning which is
scriptural do good planning Bible says
don't build a tower without first
counting the cost you oughtta have an
annual budget that's not to say God
can't move on that and it's not to say
that sometimes Holy Spirit but basically
some of these churches they lay out a
general gameplan and then they just they
jump from impulse to impulse then and I
don't know if that's what's going on
here but at some point you need to
probably push back on leadership as to
their style of financial management and
how scriptural it is but you do that
very gently and very calmly your first
goal is just to protect your house and
just say I can't do this right now and
and by the way your scriptural in doing
that take care of your own household
first the offering is in a different
category than the tie this we always
around Christianity we always say tithes
and offerings tithes and offering is
almost like it's one word and it's not
one word it's not one concept they're
two very different concept offerings are
from surplus meaning that you have your
family doing well first which is take
care of your own household first you're
worse than an unbeliever and so you've
got to do that first before you do
offerings but tithes are off the top
first fruits are off the top so it's a
different category from a Bible study
perspective there and you know you just
and sometimes you know hopefully this is
something you can solve with these folks
and and it doesn't become some kind of a
deal breaker where they're just put out
with you all the time because you won't
want to go to church there they're put
out with
you I mean that's just I won't take the
fun out of the whole thing I have to
look for another place of all that kind
of stuff started happening
you